Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. Here's a voicemail I received with
a very practical question about if it came
time to leave the country, would you still
be able to leave the country?
So it's a very good question.
Speaker 5: Hi, David, I just heard you say
in the stream that if the United States becomes
a full blown dictatorship by twenty twenty
four, yeah, you will be leaving the country.
So I've been thinking about this a lot myself.
And is it too late if you wait until it's
a full blown dictatorship?
Right?
And be able to leave the country if you're
that concerned about it happening, should
you be making plans to leave before it goes
full blown dictatorship?
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is a fair question,
which is like if things completely changed
overnight in the U.S. and all of a sudden,
no one was allowed to leave the plan of saying,
I will stay if and until it gets really bad
doesn't work because if it got so bad, you
wouldn't be allowed to leave.
I don't, you know, when we talk about the
Canadian political scientists who said the
US could be a dictatorship by 2030 or whatever
else the case may be.
I believe that it would be a continued slow
slide in that direction, and I am counting
on the the belief that I would have time to
get out if such a time came now, would I,
if it's so slow that the frog doesn't realize
that's getting burned right?
Would I know when it's time to leave?
These are all fair questions, but I don't
think it would be like an overnight no more
flights out.
I just don't think that that's the case.
But maybe some people in the audience have
a different perspective on the bonus show
today.
We will talk about the 5G airline kerfuffle
that's going on.
We'll explain it and talk about what's going
on.
New Mexico has an interesting approach to
all of the teachers out sick with Akron.
They're bringing in the National Guard to
teach.
Very interesting.
And a Louisiana Senate candidate has gone
viral for smoking cannabis in a campaign ad.
We will tell you who it is and why he did
it and what the effect is going to be on the
campaign.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Sign up at join Pacman dot com.
Get instant access and I will see you that.